Mesoamerican quiz time as tech or Mayan
as tick or Mayan
Aztec Word Maya,
one more as ticker Mayan.
Believe it or not.
These are two totally different languages.
Well,
almost there are fundamental differences,
but there's also one of history,
strangest linguistic mine melts happening here
so often I find as texts in Mayans mentioned it in the same breath or the same
keystrokes,
so I can almost forgive you for not knowing the difference between the languages
almost,
but after we're done here,
no excuses.
Okay.
First,
we're not dealing with two languages here,
hardly see Aztec,
which usually goes by the name.
Now what clear or I guess clear speech is just one branch at the southern edge
of a much larger family tree.
The youdo as tech and language family stretches from Idaho in the u s all the
way down to El Salvador classical.
Now,
what is the language spoken by the people you're probably thinking of when I say
Aztecs,
but the modern now branch actually includes a whole cluster of closely related
languages and dialects.
Myon is another story,
actually lots of stories because it's an entire language family.
Each one of these is a Mayan language.
It just to keep you on your toes.
Speakers of some of these individually,
which is called their own language.
Maya,
even when we don't to linguists,
this is,
you could tech but it's really my aton.
This one here.
It's just the now what will word John [inaudible] meaning foreigner.
What do they themselves call it though?
Well usually Yucatan,
correct language,
but also Mayan to spot some differences between as ticking mind compare basic
words.
My last video was all about the tactical use of the languages and the Spanish
conquest,
Cortez Akeelah and the star of the show.
My seen use now what Anton to turn an empire against itself.
I'll be pulling examples from these same two languages to show off as tech
versus Mayan.
Just a heads up though.
I have a little more experience with Usi Tech and then Maya.
I once got into another rather different utilize tech and language and I've
spent more time with classical now with then anyone Mayan language.
Hopefully that explains any glitches in pronunciation.
Let me start by hand picking things that stand out about their sounds.
Now,
what will is known for that distinctive?
And for this Solutio,
skip or glottal stop.
That's often between a vowel and a consonant.
It's awkward at first,
but try telling and skipping to get a feel for it for yourself.
Miss,
she got [inaudible] besides a couple affricates and a difference between a
regular and a cool made by rounding your lips.
Nothing else is too scary in the pronunciation department.
Now what will only has four vowels?
No,
Ooh,
but it does distinguish short ones from long ones.
Ah,
ah,
ee,
ee.
Also there's this relentless second to last syllable.
Stress bump up,
bump,
bump.
They know which date line Yucatan on the other hand has six vowels and it's
consonants include the ever.
So mine ejective stops that build up and release air pressure.
Call them exotic,
call them aggressive.
Personally,
I like them,
but they're on full display in this Mayan language.
So let me try this.
Cheech versus Cheech,
both and all those basic nouns in Maya are simple affair,
often just one syllable.
So now it's like,
Ooh.
And not our ready to use no fanciness,
no plural endings.
Of course this makes compounding super common.
Not necessarily longest word in the world,
kind of compounding,
but still,
Ooh,
not nouns that refer to people are often prefixed with male or female even when
that's not information you're used to including an English each.
I Ah,
I ah,
[inaudible] ah,
[inaudible] what about no,
what'll nouns?
Well,
I hope you've been practicing your because you're going to need it on their own.
Now what'll nouns have a base plus an ending?
Like may she got,
depending on the last letter in the root,
the nounce suffix might take another shape,
which is why house is godly,
not got,
if the noun is alive,
it has an animate plural.
So one may,
she got many may she got inanimate,
Carly stays.
Carly,
your house isn't alive as it now comes the fun part.
Now what we'll announce love to be possessed by possessive prefixes.
Knock off the ending,
attach a pronoun prefix and the parties at [inaudible] my house or Mocha your
house.
But definitely not at no Caudalie.
Similar Pronoun Bits are very valuable and you'll cook Dan,
but not in a way that so bound up with every now and it makes it change its
shape,
not uh,
not when not.
It's possible to think of as Tikkun Mayan core words like nouns and verbs is
sentence builders in their own right.
Check out what happens when you build a sentence using just the noun and adding
the subject marker to it,
like going from not and will not to Una it in Maya or may she got and DMA she
got in Aztec.
I spent some time with nouns and possessives because this is an inkling of a
similarity worth keeping in mind.
We'll build on it later when it comes to verbs,
both languages care about transit tivity in now what will you take a verb like
Watsi,
Makkah or quad and tack on a subject.
These are the same subjects.
We used to build sentences out of nouns.
Dementia,
she cut the way Etsy,
the Maca.
You can then add in your object knee Maka,
Nick Mcha,
Nicola,
Nicola or even need clock well with that fancy unknown object.
I think trans activity is an even bigger player in Mayan beyond just the shape
of the verb in some tenses aspects.
My display,
something called Ergot tivity.
The short story is this.
If a Mayan verb is in transitive than it's subject,
looks like an object.
Take a transitive verb Akaushi where you are the subject and you're still this
subject in the intransitive verb we get,
even though you look different,
this sets Maya and apart from both English and know what since we use the same
subjects for transitive and intransitive verbs,
I am the same and I eat it Nicola and in I fall new Etsy accusative languages
versus Ergot of languages that probably just made your eyes glaze over.
Let me resuscitate you with something easier.
Prepositions,
you know these guys,
you've got them in English chunk does got him too and it uses them for location
and relation.
So if you remember the Keene was money,
we can just say,
oh,
ducking for with money.
That's not how not what to works though.
It uses post fixes for these kinds of time and place relationships.
Like the one for togetherness is one more.
One with you or location.
Cool.
In the house.
These go beyond our prepositions though.
Switch off your Indo European mind and think internationally for this one,
take a little word that seems atomic,
unbreakable,
even like and yeah,
and now what?
And is a multipart construction built using a postfix he won.
It's togetherness or with it.
Okay.
You are officially a linguistic warrior for sticking with me.
That was just a random grammar sampling,
but you now have a gist of the differences between these languages.
Time for the payoff with your refined grammatical Palette.
Let's rewind and play the game again as ticker myon.
Okay.
How's tech or Mayan?
As tech or Mayan.
There we go.
But if he couldn't tell them apart before,
I don't think it was just sheer ignorance.
You probably had hazy ideas of similarities and no real understanding of the
differences,
but there was something to those similarities.
Something deep.
When you characterize a language,
you probably go straight for what we call the genetic relationship.
What kind of language is Spanish?
Why it's a romance language.
What about classical Noah?
You do as tech and of course John Thal Yucatan.
That's my end all true.
And we can go around breaking up pre Columbian Mesoamerican did this patchwork
of distinct color coded language families.
If we stop there though,
we'll miss out on the best part of the story.
There's another factor that majorly influences language isn't an almost
bizarrely stealthy kind of way when languages even totally and utterly unrelated
ones live side by side for a long time.
They start to exchange stuff,
not just candy bar the sugar or can I have your chocolate and is kind of stuff.
I mean,
sure,
a Mayan language might borrow has tech words just as people all over the region.
We're sharing goods and ideas,
but that didn't leave a huge debt instead of surface stuff like words and
sounds,
the languages of Mesoamerica started to trade structure.
I don't want your nouns.
I want the way your nouns and pronouns work to influence my nouns and pronouns.
Linguists call this phenomenon,
uh,
Shiprocket Bonet a language area as ticking my and participated in one of
history's greatest,
the mezo American language area show and tell time.
What kinds of linguistic mind melds were happening here.
First,
a simple one word order.
Mesoamerica likes to keep verbs away from the end of a sentence.
Verb subject,
object is very mine.
And even though classical now what was pretty free and how you let you order
words.
It tended to like verb subject,
object,
or even verb object subject.
The languages that surround Mesoamerica though they totally disagree.
They had no problem with a verb.
Vinyl syntax with subject object verb being very,
very common.
And those possessives,
they come back full force with the kind of Awkward Mesoamerican way of saying
that somebody owns something.
It's like this,
her house,
the woman,
their bones,
the dogs,
and as tech,
I think you'd say econ in see what [inaudible] but it works the same way all
over.
Of course,
that core words build sentences concept from earlier.
It comes back here.
So have fun with examples like equally [inaudible] back to Mesoamerican post
positions and prepositions.
Those timespace references love to include body parts.
So instead of saying inside,
why not say eat pig?
It's stomach for around use.
Eat DANCO on its lips or try my Upham head for in front,
like bumble taught at head of house for in front of the house.
They even count the same way,
not with your decimal system.
Their system is base twinning as take simple,
wildly 20 is literally just one count.
Units like 80 are easy,
just counted scores [inaudible] four counts as a consequence of your major.
Mesoamerican milestones weren't hundreds or thousands,
but things like 20 squared and 20 cubed.
There's separate words for these like the old Mayan buck or not with Wilson
[inaudible].
All of these and more are features of mezcal America.
Some are even rare outside of it.
Even in the very same language families.
The way to explain them is to look at how these languages converged around the
very same traits.
I find this fascinating in a way.
It's like you can probably keep the look and feel of your language,
but behind the scenes we'll all agree to work differently.
Similarly not differently.
Well,
thanks for making it through this grammar class.
I know it's a bit of a switch,
but I hope it helps you appreciate the story from last time or you know,
the next time you study a modern Mayan language,
modern Mayan language.
Wait,
did the Mayans like disappear or something?
Yeah.
And I think that happened when the world ended back in December,
2012 no,
they didn't.
But that's a story for another time.
Stick around and subscribed for language.
Yeah.